hey Francis do you want to keep your
online activity private yes I don't want
anyone to know I secretly watch BBC
comedy embarrassing that's why you need
surf shark VPN how can sharks sir shut
up surfshark is a virtual private
network available as an easy to use app
and browser extension that lets you
place your laptop or phone anywhere in
the world allowing you to access the
internet as if you were in another
country this means that I can access a
whole host of websites that I wouldn't
be able to access in the UK not only
that you can protect your online
identity by masking your true IP address
with surfshark you can protect yourself
from Data Theft tracking surveillance
and Commercial targeting and it's great
value for money because one surf shark
account can be used on multiple devices
so you can access problematic content
wherever you are and by problematic
content we do mean trigonometry click
the link below and use all code
trigonometry to get 83 percent off plus
three extra months for free surfshark
also offers a 30-day money-back
guarantee so there's no risk to trying
it out for yourself click the link below
and use our code trigonometry to get 83
off plus three extra months for free
given the evidence we looked at and we
looked at a lot of evidence we didn't
find uh evidence of widespread you know
systemic racism
foreign
[Music]
ometry I'm Francis Foster I'm
Constantine kitten and this is a show
for you if you want honest conversations
with Fascinating People I'm delighted to
say we have a fascinating guest for you
today she is one of the commissioners of
the recent race and disparity report
Mercy morocci welcome to trigonometry
thank you for having me it's so good to
have you uh listen before we get into
the subject itself just tell everybody a
little bit about who are you how are you
where you are what has been your journey
through life that brings you here well
as you said I was one of the one of ten
Commissioners on the recent race and
ethnic disparities report
um the government established the
commission about a year ago following
um George Floyd and black lives matter
movement
um to basically look into race
um and ethnic disparities and to produce
a report kind of summarizing what's
going on why disparities are taking
place and
um I was chosen as one of the
independent Commissioners uh because of
sort of my background in terms of I I've
done a lot of social policy work and I
have looked at race I've done throughout
my academic and uh professional career
I've done quite a lot of stuff on race
and ethnic disparities
um I've also kind of done lots of
commentary
um on issues of social class race things
like that
um so yeah that's why I was chosen to be
one of ten Commissioners and yeah the
report's just being published and I'm
sure we'll get into a lot of a lot of it
um
today
and so you said that uh it was George
Floyd was that the main reason because
it felt things were going so well you
know so it says the white block but so
things were going much better than they
ever have been regarding race and all of
a sudden last summer it seemed to
explode was that the real reason behind
it were there other reasons as well well
I mean
it was a catalyst the George Floyd thing
and obviously it was happened in America
didn't it and I think we have a tendency
to americanize the debate on Race don't
we and so obviously the protests were
here as well and um Everybody saw the
news and all the process that were
happening particularly in London and so
I suppose you know as the government
they had to respond to that in a quite
substantial way
um and so that's why um I guess they set
up the the commission uh and it's it's
good to have you here we've had uh at
least one I think of the other
Commissioners in fact Dr Tony cell
himself on the show uh quite a while ago
um and others involved in it also as
well so let's get into talking about
some of the findings of the Rapport uh
it's obviously been commented on quite a
lot and we'll get to the reaction a
little bit later but let's talk about
the report give us some of the the
headline I items on it because it broke
it down into crime and policing
Education Health and other areas family
breakdown all that sort of thing so if
you were to give us a summary that you
wanted people to take away from this
interview of the main findings of the
report what were they
the main finding was really that firstly
Britain has come a really long way uh
particularly in the last 50 years in
terms of just outcomes for different
ethnic minority groups I mean that that
is the big finding that a lot of people
don't like to admit especially people in
the kind of race relations industry but
we have definitely come a really long
way
um I know from surveys over the last
year there are people who think racism
has actually gotten worse in the country
so
um even though it feels intuitive to say
of course things have got better there
is a you know a large group of people
who don't think that way so
um you know our findings across the
board we looked at four areas education
employment crime and policing and health
it showed that things have gotten better
the other big thing really was that
this Bane we've all heard of Bain
blackened minority ethnic category uh is
just not a useful term to describe
what's actually going on in terms of
ethnicity and disadvantage ethnicity and
outcomes across lots of social policy
areas because actually
ethnic groups particularly when you
break them down into subgroups so black
African black Caribbean Indian Pakistani
Etc you see actually they have wildly
different outcomes so this idea that
there is one experience of
um race and ethnicity and disadvantage
split between the white group and the
beam group
um you know all the evidence we looked
at completely kind of busted that myth
um so what we found uh was that there is
lots of different experiences groups
ethnic minority groups are some are
doing really well even better than the
white British population
um particularly India and Chinese across
the board and then other groups remain
kind of at the bottom of the league
table and actually those two groups tend
to be
black Caribbean individuals particularly
children white working class children as
well
um and other groups that aren't spoken
about
um like Roma gypsy population you know
or all those kinds of groups and
actually our report was the first one
that had that gave the white category
equal weight because it would come we
weren't coming at this to say let's look
at ethnic minorities
um we were saying okay we've been
presented with all these ethnic groups
they're equally valuable and so let's
look at the data equally and so whereas
other reports hadn't perhaps looked at
outcomes for white British groups and
white ethnic groups
um we did that and
um you know finally I'm sure everybody
would have seen the headlines and
particularly from the UK
about we said racism doesn't exist so
institutional racism is a myth that's
not what we said whatsoever at all
um what we said was what we looked at
all the evidence and we didn't find
evidence of you know widespread systemic
racism across any of the kind of four
policy areas we looked at we didn't say
institutional racism is a myth in and of
itself we didn't say the con concept is
illegitimate
um actually you know I keep pointing
people who who are making the claim that
we've said institution racism is bogus
to uh you know page 36 of the report
which actually defines what we consider
institutional racism to be and actually
sets out a framework for kind of
understanding different manifestations
of racism so this idea that we would go
out to Define this concept while
simultaneously saying it's a myth is you
know it's not very intellectually
coherent so what we said is given the
evidence we looked at and we looked at a
lot of evidence we didn't find evidence
of widespread you know systemic racism
institutional racism and you were
talking about these groups one of the
things that I found very interesting
about the report was saying that
geography is almost more important than
race as to outcomes you're far more
likely to do well for example if you
live in London than if you live in
Middlesbrough yeah absolutely and I you
know on top of kind of socioeconomic
indicators driving uh ethnic despite his
geography was a massive one
um and you know for instance if you just
look at the 10 most deprived
neighborhoods one in three nearly one in
three Pakistani people live in those
neighborhoods compared to
um one under one in ten white British
people so you can really kind of map out
geography onto the disadvantages that
are taking place for different ethnic
groups and once you started doing that
you get a more clear a picture of why it
is that you know certain groups um fare
particularly badly uh so yeah geography
was a massive one and I think that's
often alongside class as well that's
often not a factor that's appreciated
um and that's where again our report
um was looking at all these different
factors that weren't necessarily
ethnicity weren't necessarily race and
we found evidence
um that these factors were actually
driving a lot of the disparities imagine
uh you you mentioned the word class and
I think people living in Britain all
have a sense of what that is but how do
you define that in the context of trying
to do an evidence-based report what does
class mean yeah so class there are kind
of um acknowledged accepted indicators
are used to kind of establish what
classes I mean it obviously it's class
in and of itself is a complicated
concept to Define because it means
different things different people you if
you're measuring kind of income only
that might not be necessarily a good
indicator but um you know with the data
sets that we used and you know for
example we commissioned
um a new research from the University of
Oxford a lot of the data we used
um was actually national uh data so
really robust data sets that have these
indicators
um in them so we weren't just kind of
making it up we were using kind of
pre-established definitions of these
things and using uh you know really
large nationally representative data
sets
um you know that statisticians have very
much
taken care to make sure that the data
sets are really robust so uh you know
I'll leave I'll leave a statisticians to
kind of um figure out how to calculate
all these things and the thing that I
find particularly interesting because I
have a background in it like you do is
education
and seeing the outcomes of the children
and particularly when you know when
people say education the education
system is systemically racist I mean
there are certain points where you you
think to yourself well you might have a
point for instance if we look at
exclusions but if you look at the
difference between black African and
black Caribbean especially the boys the
outcomes they're huge yeah absolutely
and this is another kind of point I like
to raise when people talk about
education systems institutionally racist
and these aren't just um you know people
online random the I think uh one of the
kind of
um heads of these big teaching unions I
can't remember which one recently did
come out and say that education systems
institution erases so these are kind of
people at the top of Education making
these claims often not very much backed
up by robust evidence but to take that
point of we hear black black exclusive
Asians as an example for when you say
well why is the education system
institutionally racist and you're right
if you look at the outcomes between
black Caribbean and black African wildly
different not only in terms of
um their performance particularly in
secondary school where you see black
African kids outperforming white British
kids out forming the national average
but in and then you see Cara being kids
kind of all the way at the bottom of the
league table but in exclusions as well
because actually African kids are no
more likely to be excluded from school
than their white British counterpart
it's Caribbean kids where that disparity
really is there so this kind of speaks
the point of kind of you know you can't
conflate even just saying black like I
see so many headlines black exclusions
black into this black kids that and it
just doesn't make it's not very clever
to do that not only because it's just
completely neglecting the fact that it's
not black kids it's there's Caribbean
kids on one hand African kids on the
other and even that is quite simplistic
as well
um but it feeds into this idea that if
you're black just just if you're black
then the education systems are to get
you it has nothing else to do with
anything else going on in your life like
culture or family or anything like that
but it's just if you're black then
you'll be screwed in the education
system and in life and so those kinds of
really simplistic
um narratives or analyzes just don't
help the debate whatsoever and we've
been dancing around the topic of looking
at why why white British and black
Caribbean kids particularly the boys are
doing less well than every other
subgroup why is that Mercy is it because
of the fatherlessness issue in those
communities is it because they don't
value education or is there something
else going on so we don't really know is
the probably the easiest answer and you
know in the report with one of our
recommendations is to actually do the
first proper Deep dive look into why it
is certain ethnic groups are doing
really well and how we can replicate
those factors we've heard stuff about
kind of immigrant optimism and that's
you know a theory for white African kids
particularly immigrant kids and just
generally immigrants tend to do better
um uh Caribbean kids and Caribbean
families don't tend to be immigrants
um
uh so
we don't know and yes those kinds of
factors such as family
um are important surely because you know
in the report we found
um that 63 of Caribbean children are
growing up in the lone parent household
and that's absolutely staggering to me
um because
you know that's six in ten kids growing
up and it is most likely going to be
without a father because they'll be
largely single mums so to pretend that
firstly those kinds of factors couldn't
possibly be driving any of the
disparities is you know doing those kids
a disservice I think and it's very
disingenuous and also I think the reason
people haven't touched that subject is
because then you get accused of
demonizing single parents or nobody
really wants to go down that route and
you know families in general the concept
of strong and stable families are seen
as some kind of backward right wing
thing these days isn't it so there's a
lot of reasons why I think we're not
talking about why it is that certain
groups are not doing so well because it
touches on difficult uncomfortable
um topics but
one of the other main recommendations is
actually for the government to set up
reviewing to families the kind of to
look at the underlying factors driving
that relate to family that are driving
outcomes and how families can be better
supported given that family structures
do drive so so many outcomes basically
I it just occurred to me that people
watching this were the more critical I
might be like okay so your conclusions
in the report were the systemic racism
doesn't seem to be an issue right is
that broadly accurate
it's that
given the evidence we looked at that's
not a conclusion we could make because
we can't you know we could make
conclusions that weren't rooted in the
evidence we looked at so it's not to say
it's not an issue it's just in the
evidence and in that these four areas
that we looked at
we didn't find evidence that there was
systemic racism driving so in the in the
things that you looked at which is
policing and crime employment health and
education you did not find systemic
racism yeah based on the evidence yes
absolutely okay so we're clear on that
yeah but you're not denying the racism
exists and people experience racism
absolutely not and that is why our very
fast recommendation is to tackle racist
actions
um again a lot of this rhetoric I think
about all the denied racism you know you
just have to look at recommendation one
and then you figure out no we're not
because our our top recommendation is to
actually Empower
um the equalities Watchdog um the
quality and Human Rights Commission to
do more to have more powers to kind of
tackle racism particularly in relation
to online racism and we we did find
evidence of over at racism particularly
online so
and you in fact you found that people
from Minority backgrounds experience
more abuse and discrimination Etc uh
online versus the white population yeah
yeah absolutely so and these aren't
things we're denying
um and I think you'd have to be an idiot
to or a racist to deny that you know
there is no racism online and there is
over racism in society because there's
all sorts of awful things in society
um so yes we didn't find evidence that
institutional racism was driving the
disparities but could there be
institutional racism under particular
context in certain times if you can show
the evidence for that then that was
something we went in
um being open to finding you know we we
didn't go in with preconceived
conclusions well we'll maybe get to that
later on in terms of the reaction to the
report on what people have said but on
the on the on the disparities and
outcome I think the one thing that a lot
of people feel very passionately about
including friends of us you know we have
uh black friends of ours guys obviously
usually who say well look you know I'm
not into this whole victimhood mentality
but when I was a kid by the time I was
18 I'd been a like stopped and searched
20 times by the police so
in terms of policing and the disparities
that do exist there what are the driving
factors that you identified for why some
of these things happen that way
yeah and that is true we did find a
massive disparity uh particularly in
relation to stop and search and there
was a lot of factors that um were kind
of driving those
you can never obviously really
determine why is you know a particular
office you know you we have biases don't
we all of us so not me
yeah so so you know we with that face
and that voice no one is going to
believe that
um we we can't say you know that's
perhaps biases are or aren't driving
those things they probably are they
drive everything you know
um but having said that we can go off
the evidence we have and try and kind of
look at what's going on there and
something we found because
um ethnic minorities are massively
disproportionately
um more likely to live in deprived
neighborhoods and those deprived
neighborhoods are more likely to be
heavily policed right
and so because there's more crime yeah
exactly and so when you start looking at
factors like those you know the
conditions the context then
some of it starts making sense and it
becomes evident that actually you know
you can actually explain why it is
they're more likely to be stopped in
Search and also for example ethnic
minority population is younger so
um we found that kind of drives again
white is that there's more a
disproportionate number of younger black
people for instance would be more likely
to stop and search so yes you know we
can't pin down exactly why that is but
what I would say I mean one of our
findings was that for everyone
um young white kid killed 24 black kids
are killed
um and that's between 16 to 25.
when you have the disparity of that
stock in terms of likelihood of being
murdered I don't think demonizing the
police or saying we should have less
policing is the answer whatsoever you
should have more effective policing sure
but this knee-jerk reaction of oh it's a
problem with policing you can't you know
blame policing on the fact that uh you
know for everyone white victim of
homicide a young young victim there's 24
black victims so you know can you really
blame institutional racism on that
either so again we have to have these
conversations about why it is that
that's taking place and yes it involves
you know sometimes making perhaps
awkward and uncomfortable hypotheses
relating to family and culture and all
that kind of thing and nobody wants to
go there
um Mercy let me just jump in there
because I just want to get to the end of
this so let me make the best possible
case I can for the existence of
institutional racism in the way that you
framed it so you say that the reason
that uh this is happening is that uh
people from ethnic minority backgrounds
live in deprived areas much more than
white people and as a result there's
more crime as a result there's more
policing as a result there's more
interaction
Etc right but isn't that what people
mean when they say institutional racism
that but essentially minority
populations are growing up in areas
where they have bad schools bad you know
social organization bad access to
activities for children that they can't
go out and play or whatever and as a
result of that there's more crime and
therefore it's the poverty that they end
up growing up in that's causing all this
other stuff later in life I think that's
why we have to be clear what we mean by
institutional racism because you know I
would suspect maybe many people would
describe what you're describing that
phenomenon as institutional racism but
we have to remember the racism part of
that argument that what you're
describing yes that is institutional
it's institutional something
um but we have to remember that racism
is a very serious thing you know it's
hap it has to be happening because of
somebody's race if you're gonna use that
racism word
um and what we see in the data is that
race is not a good Expo you know
explanatory factor for why things happen
the way they do
um what do you mean but when you say the
evidence isn't showing that
for example if you look at Indians
versus Pakistani and Bangladeshi if you
look at black African versus black
Caribbean
um race is not a good determiner for how
what outcomes your life will have that's
what the data shows it's all these other
factors and so you know outcomes are so
fragmented and so all over the place
some groups of you know subgroups are
doing so well some are doing really
poorly even if they're the same race
uh that's why this racism argument
begins to kind of break down quite
quickly do pockets of you know racism
exist in particular neighborhoods and
things like that I'm sure they do but I
think once we start uh kind of unpicking
that so you know for example you said
about that living in deprivation poor
access to particular institutions and
services okay well let's tackle that
let's find out why it is that they have
that poor access let's um you know come
up with policies to help them out of
poverty you know that that kind of
that's where the conversation should be
and once you say well it's institutional
racism so the system itself you know is
out to get ethnic minorities or black
people then
you know you can't go much further than
that the conversation should be okay
well if they're disproportionately more
likely to live in the poor neighborhoods
what can we do about that how can we
Empower them to make sure their
prospects are um better and that's why
it is important that things you know for
example take employment um and wage gaps
or wage gaps at its lowest for a decade
at 2.3 percent between ethnic minorities
and um the white British population for
under 30s there's no statistically
significant wage gap which I'm sure you
know everybody would welcome
again ethnic minorities we commissioned
research as I said earlier
um and into education and social
mobility and ethnicity and things like
that and ethnic minority kids you know
control for every faction they're still
more likely to outperform their white
British counterparts these are things we
should be celebrating and actually these
are the things that are going to then
impact
um wealth in the future of ethnic
minorities so let's kind of you know
carry those things on and I think that's
the way the conversation should go what
what can we identify that can kind of
have a tangible impact on people's lives
because ultimately it is as much as we
like to talk about kind of philosophical
sociological concepts when we're talking
about race um
like systemic racism white privilege all
those things you know mo everybody's
living their life in a very tangible way
and that you know the poorest people and
the most deprived people care about
putting food on the table you know they
care about their job and you know they
care about their health and things like
that so we should be having
conversations in that space about actual
tangible issues really not like you know
white privilege systemic racism Etc
um it's a very good point now we were
talking about tangible issues you
mentioned that horrifying statistic if
you could repeat it again about black
boys more likely to be murdered than
white boys yeah so for every one young
white
um victim of homicide there's 24 black
victims why I mean I still just take a
moment to think about that that is crazy
isn't it yeah absolutely and I think
that was one of the most shocking things
for me why is that
exactly is what I would say
um
is it institutional racism I mean I I
would like somebody to make a compelling
case for why that would be institutional
race and I'm sure somebody very much
could I'm sure somebody might write you
know an essay in the YouTube comments
about what that is institutional racism
but
we need to understand why
how you know culture family
in people's environment mental health
all those things
how they feed into how something like
that and to produce such a stark
disparity
um
I mean
we we didn't kind of do a deep dive into
why that particular statistic is is the
way it is
but judging from kind of all our other
evidence
it is being driven by again probably
deprivation family stability all these
kinds of things we just we don't know
because we don't ask these questions
we're too busy arguing about white
privilege half the time
um so we don't know what what really why
that's the case it's it's shocking and
it should be a national Scandal
um but all the kind of publicity that
things relating to race
um and disadvantage get are just so
confined to this these all these
sociological concepts and not you know
why the heck are so many you know black
kids dying on the street
um and also why they're
disproportionately more likely to do the
killing as well so why is that you know
we don't we don't have those
conversations and those are really
conversations we need to be having the
thing that I found very very upsetting
in the report when I was reading it was
when they were talking about gangs and
they were saying that they became a
surrogate family that these people these
boys predominantly girls as well but
boys predominantly are looking for
family in all the wrong places yeah
absolutely and I mean there's a whole
nother conversation to be had on kind of
father figures and a sense of
Brotherhood that that young men in
particular I I think are lacking
generally in society
um so
it's not surprising when somebody's you
know a kid has grown up without
um a father in their life
um they live in a poor neighborhood they
are more likely to be stopped and
searched they don't really trust the
police they hear a narrative that
Society is racist of course they're
going to find
um you know a sense of family somewhere
else right because it's we're only human
that's a the most basic kind of human
instinct
and often unfortunately there are people
who exploit that and that is why we have
um a kind of county lines crisis and
that's why so many young kids have been
recruited into these gangs because
you know people see that opportunity for
young kids don't really have you know
then they're not really optimistic about
their prospects in life they look around
there's not much to Aspire to
um
so of course they're going to kind of
look for to make money quickly first of
all and that's where a lot of it does
come from
um and they're gonna you know get into
the wrong crowds essentially so again
this issue of fatherlessness and uh is
there's lots of data particularly in
America in American studies to show the
massive effects that father the
listeners has whether it's in outcomes
where in relation to education just
criminality all that kind of thing so
um I think it's very disingenuous when
people say oh you're just trying to
blame single mothers and then they don't
want to have the conversation why don't
we want to have this conversation Mercy
because it seems to me it's a very
important and necessary conversation to
have when I worked in newham you know
you could see particularly the boys that
struggled with you know with their
education but also with the structure of
the school day getting into school doing
the homework and a lot of the time it's
because they didn't have a stable family
background yeah absolutely it we're not
I don't know why we're not talking about
I can I can guess it because
anything that seems to demonize firstly
poor people
um
the black people black women blacks it's
almost like a all the taboo things that
you shouldn't be talking about or that
of you know people you shouldn't um be
demonizing in society poor black mothers
you know so I think part of it comes
from that
um part of it comes from a you know I I
hate to say it because this is another
kind of worms but you know some strands
of um
kind of feminism and this is
demonization of
um you know masculinity
masculinity and the demonization of two
parent families or we're kind of looking
down upon people who think that growing
up in a stable two-parent household
um is the best setup for a child you
know that's uh you know a lot of the uh
I hate to say the work liberals
um you know they they think once you
start talking about stable two parent
families or they roll their eyes or
conservatives you know they just think
it's some right-wing garbage do you
think that in our desire to progress
socially we've just maybe sort of we've
the train is now running downhill
without any breaks on like we are so
Keen to be Progressive yeah that we sort
of forgot some of the things that got
Humanity through the last 30 000 years
to where we are now yeah I I think
Richmond
the one of the reasons I'm a
conservative is for that very reason
because I think you know change is done
best when it's done slowly because
Society is so delicate it's such a
delicate thing it's like a delicate
organism that you know then it requires
so many tiny Parts working correctly at
the same time many of which are just
really complicated social relations
they require stability so and I think
we're trying to undo that really quickly
we're kind of almost experimenting
um we've kind of using society as a lab
rat or something and we're just trying
to change structures and
um criticizing structures that have been
in place for you know for as long as
humans have been alive and we're just
trying to break those down really
quickly in the name of being Progressive
and yes I think
that breakdown is you know we're doing
that at our Peril I think
hey Francis do you like to keep your
online activity private yes um I mean
sure think about everything you've ever
browsed search for watched or tweeted
now imagine all of that data is being
crawled through collected and aggregated
by Third parties into a permanent public
record I'm
you are trigonometry is now going to be
a solo project
there are hundreds of data Brokers out
there whose sole business is to buy and
sell your data that's why I use
expressvpn with expressvpn my connection
gets routed through an encrypted server
and my IP address is masked my career is
over enough about the good news every
time I turn expressvpn on I'm given a
random IP address shared by other
expressvpn customers that makes it more
difficult for third parties to identify
me or harvest my data
I'm absolutely done for and the best
part is how easy it is to use no matter
what device you're on phone laptop or
smart TV all you have to do is tap one
button to get protected come on Francis
you can do the last bit come on let's do
this uh if you don't want to end up like
me go to
expressvpn.com trigger and get three
extra months for free that's
expressvpn.com trigger go to exp
vpn.com trigger to learn more
it's it's a very very interesting point
and we you know we're talking about the
breakdown of society but also one of the
things that I found quite shocking was
the lack of faith particularly from the
black Caribbean community in the
institutions particularly the police
and if that's the case if there is this
suspicion then how are we going to move
forward as a society how are we going to
progress Because unless you have faith
in institutions and and the people out
to who are meant to support you then
we're not we're never going to find any
form of cohesion are we yes a trust was
something we very much identified
um in the report as something that's a
massive barrier
um again we found different levels of
trust particularly
um in policing we found you know not all
ethnic minority groups massively you
know mistrust the police and
institutions in general
um but you know lack of trust amongst
black Caribbean population for instance
is pretty high and that's why one of our
recommendations actually we had a few
recommendations that were trying to
touch on that issue is to have more
collaborative
um uh kind of working between police and
local communities
one was introducing a local residency
requirement for police forces which some
police forces are doing just to get a
sense that
the people policing you are working with
you and are kind of drawn from the
community
um and more scrutiny of you know stop
and search
um sort of policy and uh video footage
uh body count footage uh setting up
these Community uh groups to provide
kind of a scrutiny for local police
forces made up of kind of uh panels
panel members from the local community
you know all those so there are ways you
can start kind of building trust between
local communities and police in
particular
um it's not it's a massive mountain to
climb because there are these issues of
that there is the legacy of racism it's
something I would say particularly
amongst the black Caribbean population
um who
who feel like very strongly you know
because of their experiences they click
on it from the 50s onwards of living in
Britain in a way that me as a an
immigrant wouldn't
um so I think it's a massive Hill to
climb and I think it's a really
important one
um but again we should be talking about
uh how we do that um rather than just
kind of saying oh wow institution race
and it can't be solved as the system
that's the problem yeah well I was going
to ask you how much of this is about
history because as you rightly say
particularly the black Caribbean
community did experience a lot of racism
and not just racism but actually over
discrimination as well and those two
things aren't necessarily the same both
very bad right so how much of this is
just maybe people quite rightly being
like well we've had to suppress all of
our feelings about this for a long time
you know I have a a friend who who's
from that background and he talks about
out the stuff his parents experienced
and then and when he experienced so
they'll be like yeah just ignore it
whereas really people shouldn't have to
ignore that and so all of this spilling
out that we've seen recently is maybe
just a delayed but just reaction to some
of the things that went on before any of
our time yeah and I think I'd I would
buy that more if it was the older
generation driving this kind of movement
and actually what you see in polls when
you ask people has racism gotten worse
is Britain a racist country those kinds
of questions there's a massive
generational divide and it's always the
younger people who are saying racism has
gotten worse you know it's the younger
people who've never had it so good and
that is the truth we have to be honest
um you know young ethnic minority people
growing up in Britain today there's
never been a single point in history
um where ethnic minority people have had
it so good
um and not only that because I know
people like to say oh well there's no
point comparing it's still bad even if
it's not as bad as before it's that
doesn't matter if it's still bad but
it's not uh you know the data shows that
ethnic minority young people doing
really well you know broadly speaking
just objectively not even comparatively
just objectively
um and yet they they they're more likely
to have this mistrust and think British
why is that happening
I think that
being fed a lot of misinformation
um
and you know young people have this kind
of revolutionary Spirit don't they they
think they're going to change the world
and they want to fight the system I
think part of it
um then you get old like us and you
realize there's nothing you can do yeah
exactly just become the system
yeah so I think part of it is just you
know fight the system kind of stuff and
obviously a lot of young people are
massively more likely to be
on the left and have that kind of
marxist analysis of everything so I
think part of it is that but also I just
think we haven't been Frank enough about
um
or voices who have sought to
um talk about how well ethnic minorities
are doing have been crowded out I think
by people who want to talk about how
racist Britain is and that's why you
know this is the first report really
that has focused on on those successes
um where they exist it said okay yeah
things are there's there's a lot of work
still to do
but look things are actually really good
in a lot of areas and um I think we need
more of that because
you know if you if you're growing up
thinking you're living in a racist
country and your prospects are kind of
uh
gonna be bad at every point in life
education employment then of course that
has a kind of psychological effect and
um we need to kind of combat that
um because it isn't doing a disservice
to young people I think I mean it's a
very very good point but then there were
instances where you see the government
shoot themselves in the foot the classic
example is Windrush you know in in the
the entire Fiasco at the home office and
you think why couldn't this be sorted
out why am I picking up the paper and
seeing you know I can't remember the
exact details of certain cases but you
hear people who've been in this country
for 50 60 years and you know their risk
of deportation
yeah I mean honestly I'm glad I'm not a
member of the government
um they don't help themselves
um I mean like the commission was
independent right so you know we weren't
going off what the government wanted
they obviously the government
commissioned the
um the commission
but
I think the government particularly the
conservatives and I say this as a
conservative we have got it wrong you
know we've got it wrong sometimes and uh
I think
um it's great to see that they were
compensated but can you really
compensate somebody you know for for
being treated that way
um there's no kind of justification for
it whatsoever
and um yeah I think successive
governments have really let let
themselves down on the race question in
different ways
um but again I think it's a good
opportunity I think almost
um this commission will report for the
conservatives to make amends almost and
say actually we're taking this issue
really seriously we care about
um you know ethnic disparities and we
want to you know solve the issues that
are still at that play let's talk a
little bit about the reaction because
some of the things you've you've talked
about and a lot of other things that I
never heard in the media that I thought
were very important for example maybe we
should mention it briefly the health
side of things uh one of the big
narratives that came out in the last 12
months is well ethnic minorities are
more vulnerable to covid-19 because of
institutional racism and the healthcare
system has institutionally racist Etc
the report actually showed that the
disparity in in mortality was largely
down to the sort of jobs that people did
where they lived the the number of
people per household which tends to be
high all that sort of thing and actually
ethnic minorities in this country tend
to live longer and survive major
diseases better but none of that or the
the ratio of black kids killed versus
white kids none of that was in any of
the media coverage that we saw I don't
think most people in this country even
are aware that there's any disparity
between the homicide rate for different
groups
why is that
well because it doesn't make the sexy
headlines I guess I don't think so you
don't think black kids are 25 times more
likely to die well I mean what doesn't
well when when we we've said things in
this report ethnic wage Gap eliminated
you don't think that makes a great I
mean it does make you wonder you know
suspicious of the media I think we we
all have our theories about why it is
the media teams
yeah exactly
um so yeah again with the covid thing
um
it is all these are the factors you I I
don't care about you know feelings I
care about facts um I mean that's a
truth
no but honestly I mean obviously I can't
I'm a compassionate person right let's
let's get that out of the way but when
it comes to looking at why things are
taking place I care about what we could
show in the data
um I'm you know I have the social policy
background and I care about analyzing
things properly
um so yes there are all those other
factors
um at play and that's not to excuse them
I mean it's it's not
just because yes you can explain away
disparities by for example controlling
for
um income and then you say oh well it's
because they earn less
that's not to say that's okay we don't
want these disparities to exist so yes
all those things are a problem
um
some of them are choice and some of them
are cultural like intergenerational
households
um
but this is why jumping straight to kind
of institutional racism doesn't uh
really help uh and I would hope that
even though the the kind of response to
the report has been a massive let down
have you been surprised of the response
or did you expect this
I expected it because I've been I've
been on social media and kind of active
in this kind of space for you know a
couple of years and I I've seen
how people respond to these kinds of
things when you challenge their
assertions assumptions
um
there was a lot of personal stuff I
think you know a lot of the other
Commissioners I was the youngest
commissioner others aren't probably as
active on social media and they just
haven't experienced the level of vitriol
that goes on on social media so it was
hard for them and you know when you have
an elected Member of Parliament you know
comparing the chair of the commission
Tony Sewell to the KKK I mean
effectively who did that uh Clive Lewis
uh he he he tweeted a picture of a KKK
member um in response to report so and
then I'm not an expert on the KKK I
don't think they did report such
a notoriously small black membership as
well yeah yeah
um he compared the so it was actually it
was an academic at Cambridge compared
Tony saw to
um global global is that how you
pronounce his name
that's the one um it's a Nazi she
combined him to the Nazi and Clive Lewis
I think said the commission was the KKK
um so that's takes a little mature
debate you want about this issue yeah so
that kind of thing some of it you can
laugh off but others have been really
personal and just vitriolic and
um I'm still yet to hear anybody
actually explain what it is about the
report they
um you know the data what what data they
disagree with or what recommendations
they don't like
um the people making all these comments
um
so yeah that that's the kind of where
we're at unfortunately people aren't
really trying to talk about the
substance of these issues but that's a
real problem isn't it in that we're not
having a discussion it's it's all well
and good be critical of the report but
at least do the reading and go I
disagree with this point at this point
this point and these are my reasons why
and what I worry about Mercy is that if
we can't have the discussions we're
never going to move forward are we no
we're not unfortunately because a lot of
these issues are
really difficult complicated social
issues that require
um you know in in areas like Health when
you identify a particular disparities
that's perhaps can be relatively easily
resolved by lifestyle changes for
example like obesity disparity then it's
clear what the um kind of solution for
that would be but that's not the nature
of a lot of these issues we're talking
about they're really complex cultural
social social issues and um it requires
people to actually sit down and have
difficult conversations and the climate
isn't right for that um because
you know everybody knows now that as
soon as somebody disagrees with you they
call you a racist or you know a
homophobia they'll just throw around
kind of isms
um
so people are actually scared to have
these conversations you know and
actually we need white people to on
board almost to and in this conversation
we're with you Mercy
you've got you've got two white people
with you I mean let's not forget the I
mean the last census was obviously 10
years ago and we don't have the latest
census data we won't have that for a
while but
um you know roughly 86 of the country is
white
um and I feel that's a really big group
of people to be kind of excluding from
the conversation right when it actually
requires a kind of almost National
effort National conversation and
so many white people
um I speak to and I I see on social
media they say well I I don't know what
to say I'm scared I'll I'll say
something wrong and then I'll be called
racist and then you know I'll be
counseled to essentially lose my job you
know that that is a reality for a lot of
people these days they'll say something
against BLM and then they'll lose their
job
um so
part of the problem is
the climate of discourse
um at the moment which is really just
not conducive to people having open and
Frank conversations about difficult
social issues why is it that it seems
that people who are on the right and are
far more amenable to have these
conversations but people on the left I
mean they don't have them and if they
start to have them this is what happens
we descend into epithet hurling
yeah uh
I cannot speak for those sorts of people
because I'm still trying to understand
them myself I think
we've seen
there's a lot of people on the left that
just are so wedded to this structural
racism idea
um that like almost can't see beyond
that in a way
um because as soon as you you know
challenge some of their long-held
assertions with evidence
all they see is you're denying
you know their reality their truth
almost
um
and that's so it almost feels so
personal to a lot of these people and I
think we were able to take quite a
dispassionate approach I guess to when
we were doing this report because
unlike a lot of um other commissions
none of the Commissioners have some kind
of vested interest in
kind of race per se
um we're not from the we weren't from
the race Lobby
um
is that what it is you mentioned the
word the race relations industry do you
think there's just and I'm just going to
put it as crudely as it needs to be
there's just a small number of people
who've realized this is a way for them
to make a career to go on TV and to bang
on about this issue and to ignore
everyone else to shout I've I've had
this experience of being on TV myself
where you should get shouted over by
someone who's just
feeling emotion and there's no facts no
data no rationality at all but they've
got a great career and so they don't
care if they drive Society off a cliff
as long as they benefit do you think
that there's an element of that yeah I
mean personally I find it difficult to
trust the opinion of somebody whose
entire career depends on
you know maintaining a belief that
Britain is racist
um you just have to look at um Robin
D'Angelo the author of um white
fragility who makes a fortune
um biggest racket in the history of
mankind
um makes a fortune
um you know doing these like diversity
training and all that kind of thing
we should get on that what yeah yeah
honestly it's uh you know when you're
when that's your reality are you really
gonna start saying action there's
expensive data that is really
contradicting
um so I tend not to trust people who you
know have such a vested interest in
that that one belief that they hold kind
of never being challenged so
but it always seems to me as well that
they never seem to put up any
any real data or any real stats and if
that's the case then how do how do you
have a legitimate voice in the
conversation
I mean you can't when somebody uh
they so I I feel like I have heard
people use data which is often
outdated and often doesn't really
account for the foot you know the the
full picture so they'll you know you
anybody can use any piece of data that
is you know an accurate piece of data to
maintain you know maintain any position
they hold
um which is why when you have something
like what we've done in the commission
that says you know I don't know if you
guys have looked through the thing but
it's very heavy on a lot of data yeah we
have um when you have something like
that that can lay out all the data and
you know we we spoke to
um the authors of the other big race uh
reviews that have been done by Ernest
mcgregg Smith race in the workplace
review David I mean you know we
engaged with we try to engage while
given limitations particularly time
limitations with all the data there is
out there we received over 2 300
responses from the public individuals
organizations obviously those were you
know painstakingly gone through by um
the people working behind the scenes and
you know we were really just trying to
take a dispassionate evidence-led
approach to this
and that is why there are things in
there that we welcomed and particularly
on like the successes of ethic
minorities and things in there that yes
are do you Echo what a lot of these
people say
um stop and search statistics
um black deaths of black mothers during
childbirth those are things people are
often using as statistics
um for proving that institution racism
and we put those in there because that's
the data and yes we acknowledge those
exist but that's not the full picture I
think was our Point um so I don't think
we can be accused of uh not
um having taken an evidence-led approach
and this this one thing that I've
noticed is is part of the problem as
well that with social media you get
members of the public and they've got
you know access to a public platform and
they have these discussions and they
don't really know what these terms mean
they don't really know the concept so
you know in the same week that the
report was released the I don't know if
you saw this clip uh David Laramie was
presenting LBC and this woman rang up
and she was saying to him you're not
English because you've you know
Caribbean Heritage right okay and people
then saw then equated the two well how
can structural racism not be happening
if this you know if David Lammy had an
unpleasant idiot calling them up yeah
yeah exactly and
what happens is yes nobody's denying
there's racism that racism happens you
know be it would be as intelligent as
denying murder happens you know because
terrible things happen and humans are
humans right we're not all perfect and
um you know some of us are absolute you
know bleeps so you could have just said
it
and not looked at me
so they all look at you when they want
to make a negative comparison
um so of course racism happens and you
know that late I did see that clip and
you know if somebody tries to tell me I
was in English I'd definitely be using
full swear words for sure
um because I you know I know you've
you've been on TV and you were saying
you weren't English
and you know he had an issue with that
it's just like can we just accept people
can identify how they want to and you
know I could be a woman but I I can't be
not English I'm not allowed to do that
yeah that's how that works
um
yeah people should be you know I think
people have perhaps people confuse this
idea of national identity with kind of
ethnic identity almost and I suppose
some terms like British and English they
can be both ethnicities and National
identities so people have an issue there
um I mean obviously I would never claim
to be ethnically English whatever that
is because even that's contested right
um English being an ethnicity per se
it's made up of you know but
nobody can tell me I'm not my identity
as an English so to speak so
um there is a lot of
kind of misunderstanding and of Concepts
and I think that characterizes a lot of
this debate there's a lack of clarity as
well around what people mean when they
say these things um systemic racism
structural racism institutional racism
used kind of interchangeably often do
they mean the same thing I mean did the
people who use them know whether they're
referring to the same phenomenon when
they're using them I mean so
all those things I feel like people are
kind of left to Define what they mean by
racism and that's part of the problem
with just
we don't really know what racism is
anymore so we can apply it as a blanket
explanation for it it's being very much
diluted I think um the term racism yeah
the language has evolved to say the
least uh let me put one final point to
you in the sort of spiral plain Devil's
Advocate before we go to our last
question uh one of the accusations that
was made about the people who were
involved like yourself in in preparing
the report was that while ethnically
you're all very diverse actually a lot
of the people who were involved already
thought there's no such thing as
institutional racism well they're all
sort of quote-unquote conservatives you
are I don't know about Tony but I don't
know if he's conservative but he
certainly you know he's not a woke
leftist let's put it that way right and
so the argument was well all these
people who thought institutional racism
didn't exist founded didn't exist
surprise yeah I mean I could see see
that but I think we the people on the
commission I mean I felt like I was out
of my depth almost because these are
people with you know decades and Decades
of experience you know on the ground
doing actual stuff we've got you know
um he he did um leave in December where
he served the full original term
um one of the Commissioners
um Dr Ajay Kaka Lord Ajay Kaka so
um he's got pretty much every kind of
medical Accolade you can
um think of as professor of surgery or
or something like that at the UCL we
have a space scientist for God's sake
um we had several people with phds I
think probably the majority there the
global Economist
um you know these are people who care
about data you know they have not gotten
to where they were because they were
putting ideology
um before data
um these are people who not only have
um underground experience of doing
actual you know practical work
um in lots of areas and Tony for example
has been helping young ethnic minority
people for for decades in education so
what I would say to those people is just
look at the CVS of everybody who was on
there and then try and ask yourself
whether
they got there by kind of putting
ideology on Race ahead of everything
else or they they got there actually
because they're um just very good at
what they do and they care about
statistics and they care about data and
they care about facts and Truth
I don't think they're going to do that
so I don't know why call me a sitting
mercy so something that actually
happened was so the the British medical
journal
um
they published a response saying oh
there was nobody of uh with any health
background
um on the commission uh when we have a
literal professor of surgery or
something and uh you know we have a
little space scientist
there's been a lot of stuff trying to
undermine the the kind of expertise of
people on there
um you know Dr Danby samoyo for example
she's uh worked for just about every
worked for and with just about every
major bank and she's you know she's a
global Economist like a world-renowned
global Economist author and there seems
to be kind of
um
there's been a lot of hateful uh
the vitriolic stuff trying to put down
um the personal backgrounds professional
backgrounds of people involved and I
think it's just if anything it's just
showing the colors of the people doing
that more than anything I think it says
more about them than the Commissioners
to be honest
yeah and I I would completely agree with
you Mercy has been a wonderful interview
thank you so much for coming on
um we always end the conversation with
one question which is always what's the
one thing we're not talking about but we
really should be
I I would really say to go back to what
I've said is let's talk about uh you
know the role of families the role of
fathers in kids lives and just culture
in general uh because that's you know
people like David Lammy used to make
this point a lot and it's sad that he he
doesn't really do it anymore no there's
nobody in the mainstream talking about
you know absent fathers culture the role
of culture in driving a lot of these
disparities
whether we can do anything to fix it is
another issue but you you just can't
talk about
you know as somebody I grew up in a
single parent household and I am a
single parent so
I've had a first-hand experience of you
know not having a father in my life and
it's a it's an issue that is close to me
in a way because I know that if you look
at the statistic it drives massively you
know absent fathers and strong families
is I would say the most important thing
probably just generally in life and for
outcomes so I would hope we talk about
you know culture and families more and
especially in relation to young guys we
don't talk about boys anymore it's all
about women
um so that's that's something I I hope
we can talk about more but you know I'm
not gonna hold my breath well I mean you
say there's nothing we we might not be
able to do much about it but actually as
we all know the first step to solving
some of these and acknowledging that it
exists right and that's probably step
number one there but anyway Mercy thank
you so much for coming on uh you bring
you breathed out of sight of relief
thank you he hasn't exactly been the
Paxman treatment but thanks for coming
on uh where can people find you online
if they want to follow you because you
may have things in the future that
they're interested in yeah so I'm
wondering we won't tell them exactly
what they are but you should definitely
follow her because interesting things
are watching this space
um yeah so Twitter is probably the best
place to find me at my name at Mercy
maroki Mercy thank you so much and thank
you for watching we will see you very
soon with another brilliant interview
like this one or a live stream all of
them go out 7pm UK time take care and
see you soon guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the Bell button so that you never miss
another fantastic episode and if you
believe that the work we do here at
trigonometry is important support us by
joining our locals Community using the
link below